Hi, I’m Carrie Anne, and welcome to CrashCourse
Computer Science!
Last episode we discussed how writing programs
in native machine code, and having to contend
with so many low level details, was a huge
impediment to writing complex programs.
To abstract away many of these low-level details,
Programming Languages were developed that
let programmers concentrate on solving a problem
with computation, and less on nitty gritty
hardware details.
So today, we’re going to continue that discussion,
and introduce some fundamental building blocks
that almost all programming languages provide.
INTRO
Just like spoken languages, programming languages
have statements.
These are individual complete thoughts, like
“I want tea” or “it is raining”.
By using different words, we can change the
meaning; for example, “I want tea” to
“I want unicorns”.
But we can’t change “I want tea” to
“I want raining” - that doesn’t make
grammatical sense.
The set of rules that govern the structure
and composition of statements in a language
is called syntax.
The English language has syntax, and so do
all programming languages.
“A equals 5” is a programming language
statement.
In this case, the statement says a variable
named A has the number 5 stored in it.
This is called an assignment statement because
we're assigning a value to a variable.
To express more complex things, we need a
series of statements, like “A is 5, B is
ten, C equals A plus B”
This program tells the computer to set variable
‘A’ equal to 5, variable ‘B’ to 10,
and finally to add ‘A’ and ‘B’ together,
and put that result, which is 15, into -- you
guessed it -- variable C.
Note that we can call variables whatever we
want.
Instead of A, B and C, it could be apples,
pears, and fruits.
The computer doesn’t care, as long as variables
are uniquely named.
But it’s probably best practice to name
them things that make sense in case someone
else is trying to understand your code.
A program, which is a list of instructions,
is a bit like a recipe: boil water, add noodles,
wait 10 minutes, drain and enjoy.
In the same way, the program starts at the
first statement and runs down one at a time
until it hits the end.
So far, we’ve added two numbers together.
Boring.
Let’s make a video game instead!
Of course, it’s way too early to think about
coding an entire game, so instead, we’ll
use our example to write little snippets of
code that cover some programming fundamentals.
Imagine we’re building an old-school arcade
game where Grace Hopper has to capture bugs
before they get into the Harvard Mark 1 and
crash the computer!
On every level, the number of bugs increases.
Grace has to catch them before they wear out
any relays in the machine.
Fortunately, she has a few extra relays for
repairs.
To get started, we’ll need to keep track
of a bunch of values that are important for
gameplay, like what level the player is on,
the score, the number of bugs remaining, as
well as the number of spare relays in Grace’s
inventory.
So, we must “initialize” our variables,
that is, set their initial value: “level
equals 1, score equals 0, bugs equals 5, spare relays equals 4, and player name equals “Andre”.
To create an interactive game, we need to
control the flow of the program beyond just
running from top to bottom.
To do this, we use Control Flow Statements.
There are several types, but If Statements
are the most common.
You can think of them as “If X is true,
then do Y”.
An English language example is: “If I am
tired, then get tea”
So if “I am tired” is a true statement,
then I will go get tea
If “I am tired” is false, then I will
not go get tea.
An IF statement is like a fork in the road.
Which path you take is conditional on whether
the expression is true or false -- so these
expressions are called Conditional Statements.
In most programming languages, an if statement
looks something like …. “If, expression,
then, some code, then end the if statement”.
For example, if “level” is 1, then we
set the score to zero, because the player
is just starting.
We also set the number of bugs to 1, to keep
it easy for now.
Notice the lines of code that are conditional
on the if-statement are nested between the
IF and END IF.
Of course, we can change the conditional expression
to whatever we want to test, like “is score
greater than 10” 5 or “is bugs less than 1”.
And If-Statements can be combined with an ELSE statement, which acts as a catch-all if the
expression is false.
If the level is not 1, the code inside the
ELSE block will be executed instead, and the
number of bugs that Grace has to battle is
set to 3 times the level number.
So on level 2, it would be six bugs, and on
level 3 there’s 9, and so on.
Score isn’t modified in the ELSE block,
so Grace gets to keep any points earned.
Here are some examples of if-then-else statements
from some popular programming languages -- you
can see the syntax varies a little, but the
underlying structure is roughly the same.
If-statements are executed once, a conditional
path is chosen, and the program moves on.
To repeat some statements many times, we need
to create a conditional loop.
One way is a while statement, also called
a while loop.
As you might have guessed, this loops a piece
of code “while” a condition is true.
Regardless of the programming language, they
look something like this:
In our game, let’s say at certain points,
a friendly colleague restocks Grace with relays!
Hooray!
To animate him replenishing our stock back
up to a maximum of 4, we can use a while loop.
Let’s walk through this code.
First we’ll assume that Grace only has 1
tube left when her colleague enters.
When we enter the while loop, the first thing
the computer does is test its conditional…is
relays less than 4?
Well, relays is currently 1, so yes.
Now we enter the loop!
Then, we hit the line of code: “relays equals
relays plus 1”.
This is a bit confusing because the variable
is using itself in an assignment statement,
so let's unpack it.
You always start by figuring out the right
side of the equals sign first, so what does
“relays plus 1” come out to be?
Well, relays is currently the value 1, so
1 plus 1 equals 2.
Then, this result gets saved back into the
variable relays, writing over the old value,
so now relays stores the value 2.
We’ve hit the end of the while loop, which
jumps the program back up.
Just as before, we test the conditional to
see if we’re going to enter the loop.
Is relays less than 4?
Well, yes, relays now equals 2, so we enter
the loop again!
2 plus 1 equals 3.
So 3 is saved into relays.
Loop again.
Is 3 less than 4?
Yes it is!
Into the loop again.
3 plus 1 equals 4.
So we save 4 into relays.
Loop again.
Is 4 less than 4?....
No!
So the condition is now false, and thus we
exit the loop and move on to any remaining
code.
That’s how a while loop works!
There’s also the common For Loop.
Instead of being a condition-controlled loop
that can repeat forever until the condition
is false, a FOR loop is count-controlled;
it repeats a specific number of times.
They look something like this:
Now, let’s put in some real values.
This example loops 10 times, because we’ve
specified that variable ‘i’ starts at
the value 1 and goes up to 10.
The unique thing about a FOR loop is that
each time it hits NEXT, it adds one to ‘i’.
When ‘i’ equals 10, the computer knows
it’s been looped 10 times, and the loop
exits.
We can set the number to whatever we want
-- 10, 42, or a billion -- it’s up to us.
Let’s say we want to give the player a bonus
at the end of each level for the number of
vacuum relays they have left over.
As the game gets harder, it takes more skill
to have unused relays, so we want the bonus
to go up exponentially based on the level.
We need to write a piece of code that calculates exponents - that is, multiplying a number
by itself a specific number of times.
A loop is perfect for this!
First lets initialize a new variable called
“bonus” and set it to 1.
Then, we create a FOR loop starting at 1,
and looping up to the level number.
Inside that loop, we multiply bonus times
the number of relays, and save that new value
back into bonus.
For example, let’s say relays equals 2,
and level equals 3.
So the FOR loop will loop three times, which
means bonus is going to get multiplied by
relays... by relays... by relays.
Or in this case, times 2, times 2, times 2,
which is a bonus of 8!
That’s 2 to the 3rd power!
This exponent code is useful, and we might
want to use it in other parts of our code.
It’d be annoying to copy and paste this
everywhere, and have to update the variable
names each time.
Also, if we found a bug, we’d have to hunt
around and update every place we used it.
It also makes code more confusing to look at.
Less is more!
What we want is a way to package up our exponent
code so we can use it, get the result, and
not have to see all the internal complexity.
We’re once again moving up a new level of
abstraction!
To compartmentalize and hide complexity, programming
languages can package pieces of code into
named functions, also called methods or subroutines
in different programming languages.
These functions can then be used by any other
part of that program just by calling its name.
Let’s turn our exponent code into a function!
First, we should name it.
We can call it anything we want, like HappyUnicorn,
but since our code calculates exponents, let’s
call it exponent.
Also, instead of using specific variable names,
like “relays” and “levels”, we specify
generic variable names, like Base and Exp,
whose initial values are going to be “passed”
into our function from some other part of
the program.
The rest of our code is the same as before,
now tucked into our function and with new
variable names.
Finally, we need to send the result of our
exponent code back to the part of the program
that requested it.
For this, we use a RETURN statement, and specify
that the value in ‘result’ be returned.
So our full function code looks like this:
Now we can use this function anywhere in our
program, simply by calling its name and passing
in two numbers.
For example, if we want to calculate 2 to
the 44th power, we can just call “exponent
2 comma 44.”
and like 18 trillion comes back.
Behind the scenes, 2 and 44 get saved into
variables Base and Exp inside the function,
it does all its loops as necessary, and then
the function returns with the result.
Let’s use our newly minted function to calculate
a score bonus.
First, we initialize bonus to 0.
Then we check if the player has any remaining
relays with an if-statement.
If they do, we call our exponent function,
passing in relays and level, which calculates
relays to the power of level, and returns
the result, which we save into bonus.
This bonus calculating code might be useful later, so let’s wrap it up as a function too!
Yes, a function that calls a function!
And then, wait for it…. we can use this
function in an even more complex function.
Let’s write one that gets called everytime
the player finishes a level.
We’ll call it “levelFinished” - it needs
to know the number of relays left, what level
it was, and the current score; those values
have to get passed in.
Inside our function, we’ll calculate the
bonus, using our calcBonus function, and add
that to the running score.
Also, if the current score is higher than
the game’s high score, we save the new high
score and the players name.
Finally, we return the current score.
Now we’re getting pretty fancy.
Functions are calling functions are calling
functions!
When we call a single line of code, like this
the complexity is hidden.
We don’t see all the internal loops and
variables, we just see the result come back
as if by magic…. a total score of 53.
But it’s not magic, it’s the power of
abstraction!
If you understand this example, then you understand the power of functions, and the entire essence
of modern programming.
It’s not feasible to write, for example,
a web browser as one gigantically long list
of statements.
It would be millions of lines long and impossible
to comprehend!
So instead, software consists of thousands
of smaller functions, each responsible for
different features.
In modern programming, it’s uncommon to
see functions longer than around 100 lines
of code, because by then, there’s probably
something that should be pulled out and made
into its own function.
Modularizing programs into functions not only
allows a single programmer to write an entire
app, but also allows teams of people to work
efficiently on even bigger programs.
Different programmers can work on different
functions, and if everyone makes sure their
code works correctly, then when everything
is put together, the whole program should
work too!
And in the real world, programmers aren’t
wasting time writing things like exponents.
Modern programming languages come with huge
bundles of pre-written functions, called Libraries.
These are written by expert coders, made efficient
and rigorously tested, and then given to everyone.
There are libraries for almost everything,
including networking, graphics, and sound
-- topics we’ll discuss in future episodes.
But before we get to those, we need to talk
about Algorithms.
Intrigued?
You should be.
I’ll see you next week.